[Applause]
buddy he's so sweet oh my gosh by the
way do you know what's so fun okay so
Camila and I hey
I'm so happy like that we just get to
hang out in general I know we loved it
can I tell them each other we send each
other text videos yeah like text videos
and in one of them you are so funny I
watched it twice because you're like I
can't wait to hang out
and I'm like Drew it's so nuts and I
love her so much we're goofballs on
those videos I've watched them back too
We like Let it Loose you know we swear a
little and joke around and it's just the
minute I met you I had such an immediate
connection me too well I had that
connection even before I met you because
I heard you on a podcast like one of
those long-form podcasts and I was like
Drew just keeps it real and I just
absolutely adore her like I just like
adored you and I was just like she's a
pet you're Pisces right yeah you were
for you're for a real vulnerable like in
like the open-ended no solution way
you're just like here is how I you know
what I mean we're also Prague thank you
for saying that I mean yeah we're all
such Works in progress yeah you know I I
don't think well not Douglas well no
Douglas is a white Soul he's perfect
he's such a sweetheart yeah but I I like
figuring things out I like admitting
it's hard it's hard to administer it you
don't know you have to ask questions you
got to get out of your ego especially
when I first had kids I was literally
like can I please ask a lot of people a
lot of questions from their Educators to
you know people who were child
psychologists behavioralists to other
parents yeah and it's sort of
humiliating because a society makes you
feel like you should know this do
boundaries do this do that and I was
like there's a lot of stuff I haven't
learned totally I've learned a lot of
stuff of what not to do but that isn't
the blueprint of what to do right and I
really care I'm so invested and I think
I want to approach everything in life
like that and whenever I've acted like a
know-it-all or I've got this I don't
like myself totally and and life just
shows you how much you don't know you're
so right like life is just like oh you
thought you knew haha here's anxiety
deal with that it's like so much better
to be like you know what I don't know
but like one of my therapists said
something that I really liked where she
would always be like you know what more
will be revealed and I really liked that
like just like whenever you see sit with
something you're like I don't know how
this is gonna I don't know what this
feeling is I don't know there's nothing
I can do about it oh there's also
another thing that my current therapist
said to me which I love which it's a
play on words on like you know when
somebody's like don't just stand there
do something yeah he'll be like don't
just do something stand there oh that's
nice right
which I love which is the hardest thing
because you always want to do something
about it you always want to be like Oh
I'm gonna I don't call this person and
say something oh I'm gonna
um end this friendship oh I'm gonna and
it's like yeah sometimes it's like no
more will be revealed don't just do
something stand there just wait because
that's when life just unfolds and you
without even doing anything it will be
figured out but that is like that's a
really hard that's a hard practice I bet
that is parenting right it's a little
bit of everything a little bit of
everything you know but I know I feel
better equipped now than I did a few
years ago yeah it's it's amazing you you
just I think if you're lost also get
found you know human beings tend to not
stay stuck we're incredibly resilient
look at what we just did with the
pandemic yeah I mean I admire humans we
figure things out and we it's like mush
Huskies mush you know and we do it well
that's that new energy too like you're
like not jaded at all you're like I know
I love humans I hate cynics yes so many
people are like everybody sucks like
human and it's like no actually we can
be so awesome I agree and there's so
much Beauty and goodness and it really
is every day on this show I'm like we're
gonna find it we're gonna find out some
good news we're gonna find out how to do
something yeah we're gonna have some
good conversation we're gonna be for
real vulnerable yes yes yeah and I think
where I get like lost with people is
when they're just happy all the time and
so positive I'm like no that's not real
happiness is really hard to get it's a
bit of a war that you fight and the
reward is the win yes but it doesn't
come on tap every day and it's not easy
and we all struggle so let's be honest
about that and get solution oriented yes
yeah and laugh at yourself yes you are
you're so cute that way and like
vulnerable and silly and goofy and it's
like and then we how do you all of a
sudden like out of nowhere also become
like the sexiest woman alive what's that
oh my god well thanks I mean I guess
it's like it's all all of it right it's
like you're so sexy but also but also
vulnerable it's like being vulnerable
and and being just like open and like
having so much life like that I feel
like that is sexy it's like if you
disconnect from one part of yourself
then you're disconnecting from all of it
do you know what I mean it's like if if
somebody's just sexy all the time and
isn't like yes like literally like I
told I told somebody this recently it's
like
if I like for like sometimes like I'll
get let's say there's a guy I like right
and he's like gonna see me perform that
will be the person I get the most
nervous for but I'm like I realize that
that was me being like just trying to be
just one dimensional sexy it's like no I
might feel sexy on stage but also
sometimes I feel like a scared little
girl and it's all of it like I feel like
all of that and also it's all of it
goofy is sexy funny is sexy it's all the
things so much more nuanced but how does
one channel sexiness because I'm I'm
real Rusty yeah like interesting uh-huh
no no no no it's whatever makes you feel
good I feel like it's that same thing of
listening to your body what feels fun
for you like screw society's rules you
don't have to date if you don't want to
but you also can date if you not even
date I feel like date is even the wrong
word for me dating is all about making
friends just focus on making friends and
then if you're at a dinner party and
you're you have your like your focus is
on making great friends on friendships
and then if there's a physical
attraction to somebody
then then it happens but it's natural
but you're not focused on giving like
three hours or a full night of dating to
a stranger because that's like a waste
of life I'm not kidding I just found out
that like you're not supposed to go to
dinner on a date yeah you know what
you're supposed to go on like a 15
minute walk did you know this well I
knew I'd heard about it someplace but I
also was like I told I told a friend of
mine this recently I was like why would
you just like give a whole night of your
life to a total stranger is this
revelatory for anyone because it is for
me
it shouldn't be that and that's why it
should be like it should be like I'm
hanging out with my friends that I
already know and love and know that I'm
gonna have a great time with do you want
to come
and then if it's if you guys
smooch then great if you don't then like
whatever you had a fun time with your
friends that you already know you like
if there's no friends you go on you go
get ice cream that's 20 minutes you
already like ice cream
so you know you're gonna have a fun time
you have changed my life
okay so I want to get ready for the date
I said in the intro yeah uh coming out
uh or going into commercial that you had
a tip that actually is in the kitchen
that your mother taught you yeah about
facials wait what is this tell me so you
basically get a crack an egg you take
out the yolk you just put the white on
your face and it's crazy like your skin
feels so tight
tip yeah all right well we're in the
kitchen because you were cooking a lot
in the pandemic and I was wondering will
you show me a dish that you learned to
make because this is
this is quite sexy I see chocolate I
mean strawberry
and you know what it's not even sexy for
if you want to share it with somebody to
me guys sexy equals sensual which equals
like enjoying your senses and what's
like the best sense taste
the best
but I will confess I haven't made this
before this is just like I love to go on
the New York Times cooking app okay so
apparently according to the New York
Times we combine all the wet ingredients
okay all right and daytime TV everybody
relax you and I then put our wet
ingredients into the dry ingredients all
right okay great I mean what's the last
thing you made uh that's a good question
what's the last thing you made that went
wrong I'm gonna put my wet and you're
dry put your wet in my dry
there we go
um yummy I made red velvet cake cupcakes
uh with yeah but it was it it was it was
uh with two young girls who decided like
to have the red velvet go everywhere and
then are these your daughters they it
was my daughter and her friend yes tend
to spend my weekends how old are they
again um this was Olive who's ten and
then this was me like girls girls girls
wait hold on girls it's on the
dishwasher it's a dude it's on the thing
it's on the phone wait stop stop
everything for a second oh you would not
have fun cooking with me because cooking
with me is like cooking with two 10 year
old girls like I am that messy because
I'm still so new that I'm just like
let's just focus on it not going let's
just focus on executing you know what I
mean oh it says one cup of hot water I
should put in there do you watch any uh
like do you watch like um uh like Great
British baking show
[Applause]
shoot you know what sucks it's like all
I watch and I clearly haven't learned a
thing
by the way do you know what's so funny
did we just do this wrong
what is it
hey
[Laughter]
I have never done that before
hey guys uh this is all Instinct just so
you know
amazing I want to like stuff my face
into this plate right now wait should we
put this on top of you I don't know ask
Jason okay all right honestly we could
just eat this like soup yeah right why
does it even have to go further than
this here I'll show you there you go wow
um guys don't act like you've never done
this okay
oh it's delicious my first boyfriend put
a banana on this we're good to go
oh yeah
yeah why do you eat a banana with every
meal
um because it's delicious you love
bananas that bananas will like can make
you sing a lot better I'm just kidding
oh
[Music]